il est 8h13 sur enfin votre invité sonem
à Brooke et député modé mais président
de la commission des affaires étrangères
à l'Assemblée nationale bienvenue sur
Europe 1 et bonjour Jean-Louis brolande
bonjour 48 heures après la mutinerie
avortée du patron de Wagner un premier
signe ce matin avec l'apparition
publique du ministre de la Défense
shoegu à la télévision russe alors soyou
dont prégogène réclamait la tête ce
n'est pas arrivé que montre Poutine
selon vous Jean-Luc bourge par sa
première action sa première apparition
ce matin
c'est très difficile de parler de choses
qu'on ne connaît pas vraiment samedi on
a eu cette annonce
surprise par l'intermédiaire du
président de la Belarus que il y avait
une sorte d'accord on ne sait absolument
pas qu'elles étaient les termes de cet
accord est-ce que c'était une
négociation équilibrée plus on avance
dans l'information plus on a le
sentiment que c'était une reddition pure
et simple de trilogie et entreprise en
main par Poutine sans doute parce que
Prigogine a avait espéré avoir soit dans
l'armée soit dans les services de
sécurité le FSB soit dans d'autres
catégories les Tchetchen des appuis
contre Poutine qui ne se sont pas
manifestés ou alors on peut même penser
que sa réaction était une réaction très
superficielle due au vexation voire au
bombardements qui avaient subi ces
troupes et là il s'est retrouvé face à
Moscou et je pense que Poutine je pense
mais je n'ai aucune information lui a
dit maintenant c'est fini la comédie
l'exil c'est le mais la meilleure chose
qui puisse arriver je ferai rien contre
tes troupes mais évidemment je vais
continuer parce que c'était commencé
antérieurement la reprise en main de de
cette milice sachant que ce que j'ai
découvert comme beaucoup c'est que il y
avait énormément de milices au-delà de
Wagner et que le système militaire russe
est une espèce de constellation d'une
armée corrompue entourée d'une flopée de
seigneur de la guerre qui dispose de
milices privées ce qui en dit quand même
long sur l'état de déliquescence de la
Fédération de Russie nous allons en
parler de cet état de délices comme vous
dites monsieur Bourlon je vous avais été
l'un des l'un des seuls sinon l'un des
premiers à souligner quelque chose qui
n'a pas été beaucoup mis en avant et qui
semble quand même essentielle c'est ce
que dit prégogène il a dit dernièrement
et il le dit depuis des mois il veut en
réalité arrêter cette guerre il y allait
contre le narratif de Vladimir Poutine
notamment sur la guerre sur la menace
nazie supposée évidemment en Ukraine
est-ce que vous direz même qu'il épouse
presque le discours occidental régime
il avait
dans le passé enfin au cours des
semaines précédentes il avait souligné
l'ampleur des sacrifices consentis par
la jeunesse russe le le le le le
massacre le Massac des de ces jeunes
gens l'irresponsabilité des généraux
leurs degré de corruption la façon dont
les offensives étaient menées en dépit
du bon sens et là il a franchi et
c'était quand même très intéressant je
ne sais pas du tout si ça a pénétré ce
que je sais pas que tout comment les
Russes capsent ce qui capte ce qui ne
capte pas sur les réseaux ou ailleurs
mais il a carrément collé au narratif
occidental c'est-à-dire qu'il a dit que
le crâne il y avait pas d'agression
contre la Russie de l'OTAN que il y
avait pas de menace nazie de révolution
nazi en Ukraine et que la seule et ça
c'est quand même très lourd comme
accusation que la seule raison de cette
guerre c'est l'appétit la cupidité des
militaires l'administration militaire et
politique au militaire russe qui voulait
en profiter pour augmenter ses gains
alors ça c'est quand même une inversion
totale c'est
c'est vraiment le discours le plus
radicalement oxydantal qui est jamais
été prononcé et il est prononcé par
quelqu'un qui parle avec cette
sensibilité populiste
agressive violente etc propre russe donc
c'est c'était ça le phénomène le plus
insolite dans ces événements tous
insolites nous n'avons pas la réponse
Jean-Louis bourlant je veux savoir
comment c'est perçu comment cela infuser
dans la société russe parce que il est
vrai que avec nos lunettes
occidentales on peut avoir été surpris
de voir les Russes notamment à Moscou il
y avait une forme de de passivité en
tout cas de tranquillité peut-être
apparente qui peut nous surprendre c'est
à dire que pendant cette incroyable
folle journée de samedi ils sont pour
beaucoup rester assez calme il y a pas
eu de mobilisation de la part de Poutine
le discours c'est intéressant de
comparer par exemple le discours de
Vladimir Poutine et le discours du
général le Gaulle au moment du putsch
des militaires de fait d'abord une
analyse précise sociologique de ce qu’il
Pucci ce groupe a une apparence des
vieux généraux une réalité des jeunes
officiers très dangereux etc et ensuite
il dit je demande que tout je tous les
moyens je dis bien tous les moyens soit
mis en œuvre pour leur barrer la route
en attendant de les réduire et la
mobilisation se fait à Paris partout la
poutine on voit bien que la c'est une
lutte aguichefermée entre des seigneurs
de la guerre un grand seigneur de la
guerre qui allait à russe qui est
Poutine et des petits seigneurs et un
petit seigneur de la guerre qui est
sorti de ses cuisines pour fonder Wagner
et et et surtout laissons le peuple en
dehors de ça mais alors le peuple russe
qui est évidemment toujours flatté et
qui a été flatté par Poutine dans son
nationalisme en même temps ne peut pas
mesurer l'ampleur des sacrifices qui
buissons demandés
privés le rappel les morts sont beaucoup
plus nombreux
sont beaucoup plus nombreux qu'on ne le
dit et l'inutilité profonde et là moi je
crois quand même qui doit y avoir un
seul psychisme très profond au sein du
peuple russe il y a d'abord les
oligarques qui ont tout de suite compris
que c'était pas bon pour le business de
cette opération et qui sont amenés donc
à sauter de leur balcon ou à soigner
dans les conditions mystérieuses à une
cadence qui est net il y a une surmoteur
une surmortalité de l'oligarque russe
depuis quelques mois les les mercenaires
privés ces troupes sont très populaires
et ça c'est quand même quelque chose
d'important et l'armée et l'armée c'est
incroyable d'ailleurs Jean-Luc c'est
s'applaudissements troupe très populaire
mais dont l'action les actions les
exactions sont connues issues de tous
les Russes se sont pas ne sont pas
contraires à la violence ça ça le peuple
russe a toujours été très violent il est
etc mais en revanche Prigogine était un
combattant qui était au front il était
avec ses troupes il s'occupait de ses
troupes alors qu'il faut bien voir que
tout ce qu'on dit sur la la misère des
construirus qui sont là sans relève très
mal très mal alimenté très mal et qui
paie qui l'ont vraiment que le pillage
pour pour se distraire tout ça est une
armée abominable effectivement ça ça
ressemble à ce qu'il y avait pire à la
fin de la de l'armée de zariste
c'est-à-dire une armée de bougies
commandée par des officiers qui se
fichait complètement de leurs hommes
Jean-Luc bourlange président de la
commission des affaires étrangères de
l'Assemblée ce matin sur Europe 1 il y a
quelques instants vous avez prononcé le
mot de déliquescence de l'État russe
mais est-ce que les Occidentaux ont
intérêt à avoir une Russie désorganisée
un état déliquescent avec quand même un
pays qui a larme nucléaire est-ce que
c'est notre intérêt pas du tout ça n'a
jamais été notre choix non plus je ne
sais pas compris comment un certain
nombre de très grands esprits comme
Hubert une semblait dire que nous
n'allions pas fait les gestes qu'il
fallait regarder l'Allemagne l'Allemagne
qui de spanvan nous représentait tous
l'Allemagne c'était complètement tourné
vers la Russie elle estimait qu'elle
avait elle pouvait apporter de la
prospérité de commerce en échange on
avait effectivement de l'énergie le
destin normal aurait été une Russie
s'orientant progressivement vers une
sorte de semis démocratie et et vers le
progrès économique et le choix inverse a
été fait et c'est ici gère qui a raison
quand il dit quand il s'inquiète
l'immense catastrophe que représenterait
cette gigantesque Yougoslavie parce que
c'est un peu le modèle yougoslave étendu
à je ne sais combien de fuseau horaire
de l'avenir rue si on a entendu certains
responsables politiques je l'entendais
sur le service public hier avec Raphaël
Glucksmann affirmant qu'il fallait
presque changer ce régime est-ce que
c'est
véritablement de fantasmer peut être un
changement je crois que je crois que
chacun de chacun désire ne serait-ce que
par amitié pour le peuple russe que le
régime soit différent qu'il soit à peu
près honnête c'est une cryptographie
violente le régime russe mais alors ceux
qui pensent que nous allons avec soit
des bons sentiments soit des armes
arrivaient en Russie et dicté un autre
destin au peuple russe je crois sont
vraiment téméraires tout les Américains
ont essayé de faire ça sous toutes les
latitudes depuis 50 ans en dépit de leur
puissance ils ont toujours échoué nous
nous avons essayé de faire ça en Libye
par exemple un petit pays la Libye on
sait quand même planté dans les grandes
largeurs on a essayé de faire ça là on a
carrément essayé de voler au secours du
Mali ça va pas tarder à se voir
attribuer nous sommes vus attribuer une
réputation de
néo-colonialiste etc donc il faut nous
sommes dans un monde où le destin des
Russes appartient aux Russes mais nous
devons effectivement souhaiter que il
évolue je pense cela dit que les jours
de Monsieur Poutine sont relativement
compter il semble bien que la Russie est
un peuple fière les Russes sont un
peuples fiers et l'humiliation qui a été
subie non seulement samedi allié mais
d'une façon générale depuis le
déclenchement de la guerre ne pourra pas
être éternellement sans conséquence si
ces jours sont comptés peut-être c'est
moi bien sûr bien sûr mais alors quelle
peut-être la réaction voir la
surréaction d'un animal blessé parce que
qui peut croire qu'après avoir été ainsi
humilié Poutine va continuer à faire
preuve de mensuétude à l'égard notamment
d'un prix gaugine ou d'autres autour de
lui qui pourrait le menacer qui peut le
croire j'ai pas l'impression que je suis
pas un poisson que le que prigogym
bénéficiera d'une grande aménité de la
part du du président russe mais il y a
la question de l'humiliation qui avait
été posée à plusieurs reprises notamment
par Emmanuel Macron faut pas humilier
Poutine je crois que de toute façon
Poutine est humiliée par lui-même il est
humilié par Shogun et humilié par
l'échec de son armée mais je pense que
l'avantage quel que soit le successeur
et là successeur c'est toujours lui si
je peux dire mais l'avantage c'est que
le successeur n'aura pas à porter la
responsabilité de cela ce qui est grave
avec Poutine c'est que c'est le déni de
réalité c'est que face à l'échec il peut
y avoir la tentation de surenchérir et
je pense que c'est là où l'ensemble des
couleurs de la Russie ou sur le front
ukrainien
de de manière un coup d'État qui manque
c'est un tour de vie supplémentaire ah
ça c'est ça a été que c'est comme ça
partout c'était comme ça en Turquie il y
a quelques années c'est ça a été comme
ça avec le 20 juillet 44 après
l'attentat de rentrer clair c'est c'est
toujours ça il va y avoir un tournevis
c'est pour ça que les Russes vont pas
rigoler hélas mais au-delà de ça alors
ce qui va faire militairement moi je
suis de ceux qui pensent que la guerre
est à peu près contenue que je ne pense
pas qu'il y est un vrai un vrai risque
nucléaire mais même si ce risque est
tenu comme les conséquences en sentiment
on ne peut pas le négliger je pense que
ça serait quand même mieux d'avoir en
face de nous un dirigeant qui dit
écoutez moi je suis pas responsable de
cette guerre on va essayer de s'en tirer
au mieux pour tout le monde Jean-Luc
bourgeon va conclure sur peut-être une
leçon déjà avec un peu de recul ce matin
à retenir parce qu'il est vrai que cette
fille une folle journée samedi avec un
emballement parfois médiatique des
experts etc certains ont vu presque et
ont parié sur la chute de Poutine ce
n'est pas le cas mais ce qui a frappé
beaucoup aussi de des auditeurs des
téléspectateurs plus largement des
Français c'est la nervosité affichée
lors de son discours par Poutine c'est
le dispositif de défense déployal à hâte
face à l'avancée de Wagner c'est à dire
qu'on a vu quelqu'un autoritaire qui
représentait malgré tout la force et on
a vu en quelques heures presque un
château de cartes s'effondrer comment
vous l'expliquez
au bout du compte le char de le chat de
prix gaugine s'est transformé en
citrouille si je puis dire ces cadenas
on ne fait et puis de la grande
différence aussi entre prix d'origine
par exemple et un véritable héros comme
c'est inscrit c'est que trigogine lui il
a pris le taxi
j'ai pas besoin d'un taxi j'ai besoin
d'armes pour me défendre lui à un moment
il a dit et il a fait cette déclaration
absurde conformément aux plans alors si
le plan après être sorti de sa caserne
était d'y rentrer c'est un drôle de plan
mais c'est vrai que Poutine a la
communication de Poutine le matin et
très très étrange et elle est et là il y
a une fragilité donc il a à la fois il
me semble que Poutine à la fois perdu la
face et gagner la partie provisoirement
mais il a gagné réellement et on verra
il y aura certainement une une deuxième
manche qui ne se jouera peut-être pas
qui ne jouera certainement pas avec prix
gaugine bien qu'on n'est pas encore
mesuré toutes les conséquences notamment
en Afrique de cette mise au pas de
Wagner par par l'armée régulière qui est
une armée qui est absolument impropre à
recréer une dynamique une mobilisation
un enthousiasme de défense nationale
donc
on est quand même dans un régime qui
qui n'est pas mort du tout mais qui est
qui est vraiment privé en profondeur du
ressort et de la légitimité et les
conséquences sont encore à venir de
cette incroyable honte de choc merci
Jean-Luc bourge en avoir parlé avec nous
ce matin sur Europe 1 merci et bonne
journée à vous à nos auditeurs bien sûr